they say oh you'll throughout the day
you will power test it too many times it
gets weaker and weaker and I actually
don't believe that I actually believe it
gets stronger mind gets stronger and
when I'm the more I hold the line the
stronger the hold is the better the grip
is another day you think day by day day
by day and normally like it's all
together it's all good together when you
wake up early and you get your workout
in it you just stay on track you're like
you know what I'm not gonna eat that
food that I don't need right now man
yeah you know it's so much easier but
the day we like I didn't work up late
and I didn't get my workout done and you
know what there's a donut rep you know
and if you break down yeah so you want
it you want to use a discipline
discipline enforces disciplined yeah
discipline more discipline makes more
discipline yeah it kind of seems like
that it would be just like any other
exercise right you're exercising your
discipline so that and may I don't know
but maybe this is what that means when
they say it your willpower wears down
let's say you're trying to stick to this
diet right and you're gonna be like hey
I'm not gonna let myself get too hungry
because when I let myself get too hungry
I know that donut seem way more viable
donuts are not viable
but you know the payoff yeah uh you know
d'être it um you know it's like
basically so if I test my wolf I'm just
saying throughout the span of a day or
you know however many hours when you
start to get hungry so they're saying
okay so let's say you take your hunger
to a certain point then you say you know
what I'm gonna stick stick stay strong
usually I eat way before this but I'm
really want those donuts but you know
what I'm gonna stick with it right and
you have that one that one experience of
taking your hunger to a certain point
and still sticking to it you do that you
let your hunger gone for even more
that's your willpower wearing down
wearing down but let's say you stuck to
it boom and you stuck to it that day
then the next day you have experience
going that far and your hunger and you
will be stronger and know how to deal
with it
I actually disagree with you I think
that when you stay strong you get
stronger
and when you break like how often this
happen I'll just have one bite of that
doughnut for me every single time and
then you have that one bite of what
happens yeah yeah I got everything that
one bite ten bites and all that so I'm
saying stay strong
hold your discipline in place yeah so to
compare that to like a workout right so
let's say I I do a hard set of I don't
know push-ups mm-hmm
then I do another heart set of push-ups
I'm going to be less strong on that
second set and I do another set yeah I
keep testing easier but the next day or
the next week I'm gonna have benefits
from that workout yeah so it does
reinforce um so the workout the fatigue
is that temporary fatigue then you
recover from it and then you're stronger
yeah way through that I think a better
example is like when you say no to the
one bite you're it's easier to say no to
the whole doughnut yeah when you say yes
to the one bite it's easier to say yeah
all know that so say no to don't ya